In the last video we touched on
the three states of matter
that are really most familiar
to our everyday experience.
The solid, the liquid,
and the gas.
And I kind of hinted that there
is a fourth state, which
I don't cover, because it's
usually not the domain of an
introductory chemistry course.
But a little bit of a discussion
ensued on the
message board for that video.
So I thought I would at least
touch on that fourth stage.
And that's plasma.
I'll do it in a suitably
bright color.
Plasma.
And people consider it a fourth
state because it has
some properties of gases.
In some ways it's almost
a subset of gases.
But it also has properties of
conductivity that you normally
wouldn't associate with a gas.
And just so you know, when you
first hear it you think, oh
that's a fairly exotic
thing, plasma.
And in the first video, I said
it's only something that
occurs at high temperatures,
which isn't
exactly 100% right.
It doesn't have to be at
high temperatures.
I really should have said
that under extenuating
circumstances where you
have a very strong
electromagnetic field.
Or something has to happen to
essentially bump the the
electrons, or move the electrons
off of gases that
would've otherwise have
kept their electrons.
So it's kind of analogous to
what happens in metal.
When we talk about metal bonds,
we talk about this
notion of a sea of electrons.
Let's say if we talked
about iron.
What happens with most metals
is that they have so many
electrons, and they are so
willing to give them, that the
electrons just kind of float
outside of the atoms
themselves and create this kind
of big sea of electrons.
And then the atoms
themselves become
positively charged ions.
Because they essentially
donated some
electrons to the sea.
So they're attracted to the sea
and that's what makes them
malleable and even more
importantly what allows them
to conduct electricity.
But they're all really packed
closely together and it's a
very dense structure.
Plasma is a situation where if
you take gases, and remember,
in gases things are
pretty far apart.
So you take a bunch of
gases and they have
high kinetic energy.
Although, they don't have to be,
that could be under very
low pressure.
But they're moving around and
bumping into each other.
But they're not close
to each other.
They don't have a fixed
structure with each other.
Or they're not rubbing against
each other like in
the case of a liquid.
But what happens in a plasma, or
one situation is, that you
apply such a strong
electromagnetic field that the
electrons want to
disassociate.
So let's say these
electrons start
bumping off of the plasma.
And so a solid has
its own shape.
A plasma will take the shape of
its container like a gas.
And sometimes it is described
as an ionized gas.
And it's described as
ionized because
electrons are bumped off.
And when the electrons are
bumped off, the otherwise
neutral atoms now have
positive charges.
And what this allows is,
essentially a conduction of
electricity.
Because now these electrons
are free to move.
You might say that sounds like
a bizarre state of matter,
where does it exist?
Well, probably closest to home,
it exists in lightning.
And that's worthy of
an entire video.
But the idea is that you start
having a huge potential
difference between the clouds
and the ground.
And then because you have this
huge voltage difference
between the two, you have
electrons that are essentially
wanting to go into the ground.
You have a build-up of electrons
up here that want to
go into the ground.
They can't because
air is normally
a fairly bad conductor.
It's an insulator.
But what happens is because
there's so much
electropotential here, the
electrons that are close in
the molecules up here, at least
how I visualize it,
their electrons want to escape
from these clouds.
So their electrons start
to want to move
away in the air molecules.
Whether you're talking about
the air is a mixture of
oxygen, and nitrogen,
and carbon dioxide.
They start wanting to get
away from the clouds.
So they start disassociating
and start forming
this ionized air.
And eventually, at some point,
this happens to such a degree
that you can actually get
conduction from the cloud to
the ground.
And that conduction is when the
air is in a plasma state.
The conduction allows extremely
high temperatures
and the electrons to flow all
the way to the ground.
The other common example, you
might see something like this,
well actually not like this, but
at least a plasma state,
is in stars.
And that's because you
have extremely strong
electromagnetic fields,
extremely high pressure, and
in that type of environment,
once again, I'm old super over
simplifying it, you can get to
a state where the electrons
can get disassociated from
things that otherwise wouldn't
want to give up their
electrons.
I thought I would touch on
that because it's an
interesting subject.
And it exists in the universe.
On the universal level, because
stars are pretty much
all plasma, it is actually the
most common state of matter in
the universe.
Although in our everyday life,
we probably encounter solids,
liquids and gases a lot more.
And one other thing I want to
maybe clarify from the last
video is, I talk about
the bonding
between water molecules.
And let's say we're talking
in the solid state.
So I have an oxygen, a
hydrogen, a hydrogen.
And I have some electrons here,
some electrons here.
Let's say there's another
hydrogen here, an oxygen, and
a hydrogen.
Maybe there's an oxygen here.
That has hydrogen.
And then this has a hydrogen.
And it has two electrons,
two electron pairs.
So I talked about the notion,
and we talked about it many
times before.
That oxygen is so much more
electronegative that it hogs
the electrons.
And so the oxygen side
starts to have a
partial negative charge.
While the hydrogen side
starts to have a
partial positive side.
Because with the hydrogen,
essentially all of its
electrons are hanging out close
to the oxygen, hydrogen
ends up just becoming like
this proton that's
floating out there.
Because we said it
doesn't even have
neutrons in most cases.
So this has a slightly
positive charge.
This one has a positive
charge.
And the positive polar end
of the water molecule is
attracted to the negative
polar end.
And I called it polar bonds,
and it shows you my memory
from high school chemistry is
not ideal, I really should
have called it hydrogen bonds.
So this is a hydrogen bond, and
this is a hydrogen bond.
It's just a matter of
the name I used.
I just want to clarify that
because that is what's
typically used in your
chemistry class.
I don't want to confuse you.
And that is just the bond that
exists from a partially
positive hydrogen atom.
Because its electrons are
hanging out near the oxygen.
And a partially negative
oxygen atom
in the water molecule.
Because it has stolen
all of these
electrons from the hydrogen.
You draw it like that, it's
called a hydrogen bond.
And hydrogen bonds tend to
form between hydrogen or
really only a handful of super
electronegative atoms. And
that's nitrogen, fluorine,
and oxygen.
And these are actually the three
most electronegative
atoms. So the nitrogen, NH3,
when it bonds with hydrogen,
is essentially so
electronegative that you have
the same situation.
All the electrons hang out here,
so you have a partial
negative charge, partial
positive on the hydrogen ends.
Same thing with hydrogen
fluorine.
You get the same HF.
You get the same type
of hydrogen bonds.
And so in this case, these guys
would be attracted to the
nitrogen part of other molecules
and would form
hydrogen bonds.
I just want to get that
out of the way.
And with that done, I think we
can return to some of the
ideas of the last video and
actually do some problems.
Let's take the case
with water.
Actually, let me just state the
problem first. So let's
say that we have a